so let's talk about buffett is it okay
if we talk about another capital it's
fair to say that warren buffett is one
of the greatest capitalists of us of our
era a democrat
a a independent independent
read his book i don't know if you've
ever read his book you ever read his uh
what is that one book uh uh snow huh
snowball effect
you ever read it it's a few thousand
pages it's every week every day
that's his new sunday yeah
by the way it's actually if you don't
read it listen to the audiobook okay
and i'm recommending this to everybody
you will learn so
much about how he became who he is today
personal life marriage how he managed it
what happened to his wife at the end
you know his parents the influence of
his parents republican party democratic
party how he got involved
all of it fascinating anybody could you
sell that guy a 25 million dollar house
he still lives in his no you could
house in omaha that he's lived in for
like 50 years he's a different type of a
capitalist where you have to save your
money and and be
smart what you do with it i like that
guy he's kind of like that guy
he eats mcdonald's every day uh for
breakfast and
the market whole foods would have been
better for him but you know he's
90s 90 and he's doing great and he
drinks he says what he drinks eight
to eight coca-colas a day is what he
drinks i think he's trying to get
everybody else to drink eight because
but
he's the biggest shareholder so let's
talk about buffett it's got a few
different things that we got to cover so
let's try to get all of this first one
is warren buffett says fixed income
investors face bleak future
despite the recent sell-off that send
treasury yields to their highest point
in a year
as high as 1.6 bonds remain unappealing
and should be avoided legendary investor
warren buffett says
in his annual letter in berkshire
hathaway shareholders on saturday bonds
are not
the place to be in these days he added
in certain large and important countries
such as germany and japan investors earn
a negative return
on trillions of dollars of sovereign
debt let me read that one more time
he said in certain large and important
countries such as germany and japan
investors earn a negative return on
trillions of dollars of debt
fixed income investors worldwide whether
pension funds insurance companies or
retirees face a bleak future
buffett noted that the income available
from a 10-year us treasury bond at the
end of 2020 was 0.93 percent
which has fallen 94 from 15.8 percent
in 1980 what's a bad example to use
because 1981 is jimmy carter
but typically three to five percent is
what you had it's still a big drop off
that we've had so
thoughts on what he said about fixed
income
i actually agree with agree with him
he's looking for the highest growth
and that's why he
bought back all these berkshire hathaway
shares right
i i think with fixed income um
it's really good when
the returns are great and you feel
comfortable and safe
when the economy goes down but in time
of such
extraordinary growth why would you want
to do that
i would agree with that but i think
there's an area that's the concern i'm
curious to know uh
what are your thoughts about uh well i
mean i talk to a lot of millennials
about investing especially in the stock
market i'm a
big fan of investing in the stock market
you know and diversify and having some
crypto in your portfolio
and the conventional wisdom is have your
age in stocks and
or bonds and kind of have like if you're
30 years old to have 70
stocks 30 bonds if you're 80 years old
80
bonds 20 stocks that's sort of the
conventional wisdom but at this point
you know unless you're 80 and you're not
taking on any risk why would you be in
any bonds at this point i know like
anything so
when you have someone like uh warren
buffett even saying like
what the hell are you doing in bonds uh
you know i try to
put the people first and and and make
recommendations to them
you need to be in the stock market i
mean obviously if you're in the if
you're looking for a house and you want
to invest
awesome but you need to be in the
equities
yeah he's he's talking about what is his
concern about not being a fixed income
because fixed income is not going away
it's not like it's going to be going
away but
here's what you're looking at to your
note right now if you got a two-year
treasury what is it 0.135
yeah i mean if you've got a money five
year is point seven
two eight if you got a ten year note is
one point four four it's going to take
50 years for your money to double so i
put a hundred thousand dollars in there
50 years from now i'm 92.
yeah it's gonna be two hundred thousand
dollars why not just keep it in cash
what's the point well no it's not even
cash cash if you don't know what you're
doing this is still better than if you
stay in cash
better but not liquid and you're what's
the point you don't know what you're
doing it's still better but watch the
third year yeah a
30-year treasury note 30-year
yeah 2.2 percent why so so the challenge
isn't that you know whether you believe
it or not i actually think these things
are going to go up in the next few years
i think these numbers are going to go
well they can't go down no
they could go down i think they're going
to go up the next three to five years
because uh the market is going to take a
hit when it does bonds are going to come
back up
but the concern is the following okay so
if i put 30-year note at 2.2 percent you
know rule of 72 30 76
72 divided by 2 is what 36. it's 2.2 so
it's 30
32 years gold right now 1700 bucks
do you think gold is gonna double in the
next 30 years
double double in price 30 years yes
do you think it's going to be 3 500 an
ounce 30 years from now
possibly possibly do you think it could
you know go
maybe not double go to you know seven
thousand dollars announced 30 years from
now 30 years from now
gold we don't create more gold gold is
gold
do you think the price an ounce of gold
will be seven thousand dollars
30 years from now i don't i mean i i i
with a limited supply and
and high demand then possibly yes this
is this is the
the point i'm trying to make to you is
like two percent on a third year
who the hell in their right minds would
lock in their money for 30 years right
now at 2.2 percent
who's doing that institutional investors
investors
yeah pension funds yeah i mean take a
little risk
i mean what do you but over 30. but i
tell you depending on the age bracket
and where you're at with your risk
tolerance say you're dealing with
somebody that's 60 years
old i don't even know if a 60 yeah i i
would probably be more focused on having
a
fixed income fund to put money into
because i actually think it's going to
go up in the next few years i don't
think these numbers are going to stay
i don't think buffett is saying it hey
it's a bad time to be in of course it's
a bad time to be in but i think he's
going to be in three years from now
it depends like i'm not thinking of
institutional investors i'm just
thinking of
you know i'm a person and i'm looking to
invest like that's what i'm you know
so if you're looking to for growth and
you're
30 years old there's zero percent reason
you should be in bonds at this point
like
i can't think of a reason i mean maybe
there's some out there if you're
conservative what have you but if you've
made your money
like susie orman who's a pretty famous
financial
she's saying that she's all in bonds and
they're like well why the hell would you
be in bonds she's like look i've made my
millions
why do i want to have any risk
whatsoever i'm 70 years old
it becomes about wealth pricing yeah i
just can't i'm keeping my money i'm good
but if you're looking to like for me i'm
in you know growth strategy i want
you know returns and i want my million
to go to five million yadda yadda yadda
equities stocks risk bitcoin commodities
but
not bonds so depends where you're at so
the older and more conservative you are
sure stick to bonds but if you're
looking for growth
no that's the the the th this is not
working well so let's talk about the
buy-back so he's buying back his shares
okay and he's talking about america is
the greatest country in the world
there's
never been a better time to be in
america you know etc etc
what are your thoughts when he is buying
back his own shares and we're not
talking about like a little bit
25 billion of his own shares they're
buying back
well you talked about where his mindset
was this he's clearly
bullish on his own company and he thinks
that the stock is low
and if he's gonna how do you as an
investor process
when buffett says don't worry about
buying my share i'm going to buy 25
billion of it
how do you process him doing that he
believes in his company and he believes
in america and i mean
any time here's something i'll say about
buffon
any time not that i'm a doubting america
anytime i'm just like feeling a little
uneasy with what's going on in the world
there is something really cool about
being reassured by warren buffett
bet on america don't bet against america
like there is something just that
reminder
is pretty cool you know you yeah being
from bosnia hearing things like that
like what how does that make you feel
when you hear
buffett just being like he's the
pre-eminent
thought leader as it relates to
investments and
finances and knowing yes he made
his money here right but
he is just so wise and you know
90 at 90 years of age he's seen it all
pretty much
um i i'm the same way like i want to
know what his thoughts are and what he's
doing
to gauge and look at the crystal ball
because we don't have one
where this market is going to lead us to
because it's it's even though it's so
good and so hot right now it's like
you wonder what's going to happen in
five years so looking at what he's doing
i i'm
also a big believer in in sort of if you
believe in your company
buy back your shares you know where your
money is going
um you're not going to just put it into
treasury bonds
um but i believe in america i believe in
american business and
innovation which is something you know
however much you want to look at
investments in in europe and
asia and there's some amazing companies
there when you look at
american innovation and technology which
is where all of the new growth is coming
from where
that's why walmart is looking at fintech
you know
you're looking at um mostly american
companies
you know the the one question i have is
the following
has uh buffett lost his ways okay
and i know it's a listen you know to say
something like that it's pretty bold
statement to go up against the guy
that's worth nearly a billion dollars to
say
kai do you have an email are you
checking 80 or no 80 billion i mean 80
billion is 80 billion
but but i'm going to show you data here
for you to look at that uh uh uh
so it's it's comparing how berkshire
hathaway is done versus s p 500 i don't
know if you guys seen these numbers or
not
also regarding kind of how they're
growing so big at a certain point that
it's harder to pick investments because
you gotta pick winning stocks
essentially
yeah but you got to see how he does
against snp if there's one person he
cannot lose to his s p 500
that is not good in his world like you
can lose to ray dalio you can lose to
anybody else you cannot lose to smp5
he's such a big proponent of just the
index and
nothing just look at the link i sent you
that's right
that's the one as well that's the one
january that's a good one to go to
so go up right there okay can you make
that a little bit bigger yeah make that
a little bit more bigger okay so check
this out
2020 okay so the light blue is s p
500 the dark blue is berkshire hathaway
right
kai stop look at 2020 okay s p 500
did 20 he did four percent
look at 2019 s p 500 did 35
he did 10 look at 2018
s p 500 lost say 5 he made
3 fixed income 2017 even match 2016 he
wins look at 2015.
he lost 15 percent s p 500 made two
percent
2014 he wins double 13 tie game 12
tie game 11 he loses 2010 he wins 2009
he got
crushed right 2008 about the same
2007. if you look at seven six he
destroys them right
but go to 2000 look how he did in 2000
crushed smp5 look at 1999 he lost right
because
that's the dot-com era etc so you know
you know the the the era of
berkshire hathaway the one thing the
market is questioning is the following
look when he sold his 10 11 percent he
had in those four airlines remember when
he sold like
he owned 10 percent of united 10 in the
american 10 and all these guys
sold them right at the beginning of the
pendleton bad time to sell it because it
went 10x
it went 10x six months later so that
cost
them some money here so my biggest
concern is the following
when you think about uh elon musk
and tesla would you do you think tesla
is going to sell
if elon musk is no longer with us if
they keep creating their products
you think it's going to sell i think it
is because i think it's a
good car i think it's a very very good
product that they're producing is iphone
selling after steve jobs
why because it's a good what good
product mac it's a good product they
produce good product
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody bye